[Music]
hello welcome to another episode of
what's in the box I'm Davey
go ahead that's right man we're gonna
unbox ship as we always do this one
requires the knife these two pieces of
monstrosity in the way which you got to
get out of the way there liftoff so
while we lift them off like rocket ships
then countdown ten nine that's too long
three two one I'm sensing a theme right
here man and you know what that theme is
black power no it's batman v superman
check it out
I feel that it's crazy right like this
when I was a kid in in Catholic
households they would have these little
dolls of Jesus and then he would change
his robe for like it's the Lent put the
purple on this is my version of that
dude like I would totally put this in my
house this is Jesus no yes you know who
makes this Sideshow Collectibles that's
who makes the sideshow makes this as
well the Batman Moses Jesus
[Music]
everyone saw that he did it like pagans
he broke the back let me see guess how
much you owe this is the Batman modern
age premium figure from Sideshow
Collectibles this gets sadder and sadder
limited to 2,000 now limited to 1999
thanks to you [ __ ] [ __ ] weighs
30 pounds
I'd say $7.99 7.99 $709 you've lost all
count how much is a carton eggs I don't
know but it doesn't Hollywood I'm gonna
tell you right now it's not that I feel
this this is fantastic that's what
you're trying to feel before you get the
belt is wonderful how much $6.99 what a
man of little imagination you are you're
like $7.99 doc I can't think 696
literally just went down a hundred bucks
keep dropping you let it eventually
$5.99 you've gone for nine you've gone
399 up a little bit this is bad 30 baht
$45 429 19 that's it yes deal that is
Adi oh you know the deal is they're
gonna put it in a box and be like some
[ __ ] jackass broke this oh so now you
pick it up from cream 99 how about let's
talk about Superman here since you can't
mind no one know a little bit more about
it sure this is based of course on Henry
Cavill yes they also make one based on
Christopher Reeve which would you rather
have let's be honest Christopher of
course right like Christopher even
Superman we grew up on all right man so
how much you think size of that the
piece of this I would say $2.99 let's
talk about Superman here since you can
nine no three $79.99 so in Batman V
Superman Batman wins unless you're
looking for savings in which case the S
is for Superman
now we get to do what we always love
doing whipping out a knife severn things
seeing what's inside playing with the
juicy guts
look at that I'm so proud in all these
shows holy [ __ ] yes [ __ ] the jokes
people we got something big here son one
oh Lord oh yes oh look at all these
fabulous prizes of [ __ ] we know that guy
we know this guy just dude I'm not kind
of wants to buy a nacho I think she was
in the Fast & Furious I met that guy on
a plane that's openness [ __ ] dude okay
so four years we bought Batman toys
yeah bought and [ __ ] that always has
some rendering of Batman some drawing we
know that guy you know I'm saying like
the rendering of Batman this time like
we've seen his dick like we're so close
to this guy's crazy man like it puts us
in the movie even though we had nothing
to do with it you Riddler me penguin
then alright man who's making these toys
what's the say on his ass Mattel oh he's
owned even aqua be the king of the seven
seas deep Brandon as well this is
mountain monumental Aquaman you mental
if you will like they're finally
admitting that this character exists
outside of the cartoons and the comic
books dude now this that's nice dude I'm
so mad I'll field of why does he have a
kid a little weird they made his hand
that was the thing I always bugged me if
you're fighting in a suit of armor why
would you wear Cape you know me unless
this is made of like kryptonite so that
he could whip it and be like should cup
oh that's a good idea Zac's night hot
that right like call us this is him when
he's not in his armor this is like the
normal Batman suit which Zack Snyder
nailed this costume dude this is the
best-looking Batman suit we've ever had
in a movie I've held the real shield No
ow
[ __ ] yeah I held the real shield do
that the that DC Comics special they
brought the props are stored in this
shield so I saw the real thing this is
incredibly close to the real thing
finally Oh a woman figure as opposed to
like this sausage party figures five
through eight coming soon to five six
seven eight for the figures so the next
four adorable you know your math is on
your hands like you're a human abacus
you're like one two three four and so
where there's four figures you believe I
got a guess it would be Lex Luthor
probably a doomsday
it's gonna have the first P ad live
first theatrical live-action film
appearance of Wonder Woman she brought
her own movie force a cartoon movie said
TV showed never had her own movie
Aquaman
okay he's not at his own feature yet
either
splash burst live-action film flash
although they're doing a brilliant
[ __ ] flash yes on TV that I've right
now directing an episode ruining flash
as we speak right now and who else
cyborg every kids fade this is heavy you
feel this oh I could get past the Tate's
as villains they don't kill him he
concussive zamora you know he's always
got crazy villains cuz he punches him in
the [ __ ] head and then they go to the
mental hospital and they're like I can't
lead straight never start with the head
the victim gets all fuzzy
the follow-up movie Justice League is
gonna be a two-part movie comes out 2017
and 2019 so they've kind of left Man of
Steel off to the side but they brought
Man of Steel into it it's crazy dude
it's like when families break up and
like some dude marries like a 20 year
old and has a new kid who's like this is
my family and the one kid left behind is
like but Dad what about heartbreaking
you know them saying how much you think
you would pay for a metal diecast
Batmobile model kit it's 9 inches long
and fully assembled just like my wiener
yeah do you have to be Bruce Wayne to
buy this or could a Clark Kent to the
fletc I would say wow I'm [ __ ] crazy
optimistic world you look you look must
live in Metropolis we in Gotham City
understand that something this nice goes
$49.99 how much you think that
multiverse figures go multiverse figures
are $19.99 excellent pull oh my god like
well done there are complaints on these
figures online already so their
complaint is it should be a fist more
than a cup tan even if Ben Affleck hit
you with a fist where he didn't close it
but he just went like this man Affleck
did that I jump up and put my wiener in
it
do that now that's a clever defense I
hear this is gonna keep the bottom on
we're good I thought so we're on our
nine trying to put together this [ __ ]
Batmobile I'll be honest with you I've
been huffing diecast metal glue for
hours if you're looking for something to
give to a kid like shut the [ __ ] up this
is the toy
[Music]
[Applause]
why can he do this cuz he's like good
times we get times oh that's your bull
of all the songs you can go to man can't
pull some more turn kids watching the
show likes that disco but this one if he
would like do that stanky leg there is
the appearance of a gun in the Batman V
Superman trailer it's it's gonna SH but
it's not a gun it's like electro nerve
disabler so your spine sever bernard
shaw's well he says he goes the other
dude you go hey i don't you don't use
guns I said I don't like guns I never
said I won't use one you know that's a
pretty badass Batman lying dude I'm damn
clever don't be surprised if you see
that show up in a Kevin Smith comic book
one day one more time I thought you
didn't use guns
I never said I didn't use and don't go
all Clint Eastwood I'm what - Clint
Eastwood Island here we go
I thought you didn't like guns I don't
like punk so I give you a little horn
'old what you talking about well if
something I got a can I give you
something better to work with there we
go I brought you in my guns
you write the [ __ ] line I was giving
us the problem we have in our movies
when I write the line but you wrote the
line no I was giving you a dramatic
[ __ ] turnaround that was way too
dramatic you drive [ __ ] two sequels
through that [ __ ] mansion I heard the
dramatic [ __ ] the alien thing in the
walls one more time here we go [ __ ]
take nine [ __ ] uh how about you don't
like guns I said I don't like guns I
never said I won't use them that make
sense we go back-to-back yeah all right
no good [ __ ] birds in this movie well
I feel like we got the figures here
let's try and act out a scene from
Batman V Superman 'take the lady figure
cuz you're gonna do horrible things with
her Oh what time is it
dawn dawn of Justice [ __ ] hey whoa whoa
whoa get your hands off my woman Jesus
Christ at all of your stories are so
primitive so there it was we opened up
the box and we saw deep inside the
psychology of Jason Mewes terrifying he
has a daughter I just wanna say that for
the record you want to see us open up
some other things here on what's in the
box stuff like this man we love doing
this [ __ ] right to the screen junkies a
Twitter or Facebook
tell us them anybody just put the word
out let somebody know what you want to
see us open man because that's what we
do here on the show called what's in the
box for what's in the box I'm Kevin
Smith Jason Mills I guess what in the
box this week were some pretty bad [ __ ]
awesome and we know this guy and I won I
jerked off to the sky
[Music]
you
[Music]